foreign
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to the
lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout happy international women's day
as well
uh we are here
in san francisco california it's
wednesday at 11 a.m we are have a lot to
talk about today you're gonna bring rob
hanley around later on the show but i'm
here with reviews editor pete brown
greetings what's going on not much you
were just talking about something about
samuel jackson before we went live he
there's some video he was in yesterday
where i think he was looking at the top
google searches that auto populate when
you put samuel l jackson and the second
one was does samuel l jackson like anime
he's like hell yeah i do hentai too
[Music]
uh i know someone else who likes anime
callie plaggy what's up hey that's a
great transition you've been doing a lot
of anime coverage here lately i have if
you go on uh gamespot universe on the
youtubes uh you can see both
peter and mike watching anime cajo and
food wars food wars food wars that one
was shoko soma so what does that mean uh
just he it's a battle it just means food
wars that shows battle between food
borderline hentai
it was drawn by a hentai artist yes oh
that's right i remember you telling me
that yeah there's a lot of influences
yeah that's my introduction
unfortunately we're not talking about
hentai well i'll probably bring it up at
some point today uh but as usual we have
the twitch and youtube chats up here so
feel free to chime in i have a lot of
twitter questions about nir automata or
automata i still haven't figured that
out yet uh shadow of war
breath of the wild which i'm sure
everybody's been playing uh i do want to
get through a few news items but first i
have
a giveaway uh we have this like vault of
kind of special editions and whatnot
at gamespot and we've been trying to you
know empty it out and do giveaways uh
we have a few amiibo unfortunately it's
not a breath of the wild amiibo this is
uh as you can see princess peach of uh
from zelda
so that's kind of a tie-in no i'm just
kidding and i know it's not i think
she's zelda's sister uh we have princess
peach i'll give you this one oh i get
toad too and toad
toad time said toadstool he's so uh yeah
and then we have a pixel pals too luigi
oh yeah i'm just like assembly lining
these into your hands get all the
nintendo things uh so gamespot's gonna
tweet out about this giveaway uh follow
gamespot retweet that tweet and then uh
later on the week we'll pick a winner
based on uh just kind of
randomly pick a winner i don't know how
else to describe that but yeah i'll
bring this back up at the end of the
show and uh we can
i'll remind you that cool few news items
to get through before uh we get into the
bigger segments today uh ghost recon
wildlands that released
yesterday if you're watching this now
well you would be because it's live uh
ghost recon wildlands from ubisoft's ps4
xbox one pc uh we're not going to talk
about too in depth today because we
haven't played a ton of yet uh reviewing
progress is up from miguel concepcion
yeah and by the end of the week he
should have his final thoughts cool uh
yeah it's a you know like co-op open
world four player co-op i believe
one to four player if you want to play
it by yourself you could but apparently
it's better co-op i would assume as
these things are that's what i've heard
have you played it yet no but i've heard
it's better co-op i'm going to try it
out i just talk about it more next week
how are you going to get people to play
with you when everyone's playing zelda i
don't know that's the main
issue right now there are some good
games coming out right now um
also there's a day one patch uh here's
what's in it we have uh the new story up
whoops turn my volume down my laptop we
have the new story up on gamespot about
the day one patch if you're interested
in getting this game but you can see
it's up on screen right now
um to be vehicle improvements if you
know how the vehicles work right now
then they're gonna be improved uh
regarding mission synchronization for
co-op uh and then fixes for various
progression blockers
uh various crash fixes stability issues
and whatnot so if you're interested in
the game does that day on patch it's out
game should be a little more stable than
it previously was apparently uh another
news item overwatch's new character
orisa if you've been playing the ptr uh
the robot tank character she won't
arrive until later in march jeff kaplan
the game director was saying that
they're giving her a little more time
because they need to balance her out a
little more she's kind of like a tank
have you played her yet mm-hmm i'm
really excited she's like a tank uh kind
of like a hybrid i think tank
defense hybrid from my understanding i
could be wrong i haven't played her yet
but she will be out later in the month
like i said jeff kaplan said they're
working on balancing her out i think
it's it was too easy to get her ultimate
or something at first if you're familiar
with the game i know you hate that word
but that's what it's called ultimate
remember in time too all of our
discussions you said it's it's not an
alternative but if it's called ultimate
in overwatch i'm called an ultimate and
i'm cool with it yeah semantics yeah uh
so yes yeah speaking of overwatch yes
good segue uh later on at 1pm uh
chastity and shiva will both be playing
overwatch for uh international women's
day it's they're going to be playing i
believe they're just checking out
playing all the female characters cool
and uh do you know what platform will
they i'm not because if it's pc they
could be playing orisa or pc still in
the ptr pc yes okay pc so they'll be
playing arisa eric
she's still in pc probably not i don't
think they're going to do ptr okay never
mind so yeah but anyway 1pm here at
gamespot on twitch or youtube you can
watch that that'll be chastity and shiva
uh both who play overwatch and know the
game pretty well uh cool way to
commemorate the day uh we also have
something tomorrow starting um pete
brown and rob handler who will be coming
on later in the show are starting the
triforce spell t-r-y yeah
explain it to me quick i'm gonna bring
it up later in the show but it's really
cool and i'm excited it's uh it's
basically gonna be just me and rob
[ __ ] around in zelda
we're gonna the opposite of a woman's
day stream sure
we're gonna see
we're gonna set like you know
how
oh no yeah where what and how for each
episode so we're gonna pick a location
set an objective and then limit
ourselves uh with certain rules and uh i
mean that's the current working idea
really we're just gonna have fun playing
zelda one way or another
and cool yeah we'll try out some weird
stuff hopefully yeah we're not gonna be
playing like from the start of the game
we're gonna be
starting with sort of a later game save
so we have a lot of different variables
to work with and we won't really spoil
stuff cool uh and then the last news
item more on the entertainment side uh
logan the last wolverine movie
supposedly with hugh jackman or last
wolverine movie in general i'm not too
sure had a huge u.s box opening box
office opening this weekend uh 85.3
million
that's a massive box uh 85.3 million uh
followed close not closely but followed
by get out the uh new horror movie from
jordan
and then
michael key
keegan i don't keegan michael i don't
think he's michael i think it's just
jordan right i always confuse the first
names because i know it's key and peel
but yeah so get out did pretty well too
at 26.1 million but if you haven't seen
logan yet apparently it's awesome we
have uh obviously gamespot universe
covers a lot of uh those kind of movies
uh you know comic character movies uh
anything related to
you know like logan we have a lot of
coverage on it uh we have a recap we
have reviews we have kind of like an
explainer for
if you want to go into it with uh
knowing the premise and whatnot yeah
they did a cool video um reacting to it
chastity also who's gonna be on that
stream she was in this video yeah um
just kind of breaking down like oh this
was different in the comics and um
it's not too overwhelming if you're kind
of not a big comics person it was kind
of because i'm not a big comics person
watching it i i got good information and
it wasn't overwhelming so yeah same here
i'm not a i'm not super into like comic
books or x-men in general but it uh
seems like it's just a good movie you
know like that used to be the qualifier
oh this is a good comic book right it
used to be but then like
i don't know captain america two iron
man
the dark knight trilogy kind of came
along i just saw them
i really i do want to say i really like
that that movie had an r rating because
the man has knives in his hands titanium
skeleton apparently it's pretty brutal
he has knife hands yeah you saw it and
it worked so it should
appropriately brutal yeah okay cool i'm
looking forward to that i'm gonna go see
that and i want to see get out i'm
behind ever since the oscars but anyway
all right cool going on to our first
segment uh in the
tumult of the
zelda breath of the wild release
platinum games has a little uh well
platinum games worked on it yeah square
enix revealed released near automata do
you say automata or automata it depends
on my mood
i'm gonna say automata uh it released
it's really good we gave it a nine out
of ten miguel concepcion who's not here
right now he is reviewing ghost recon
wildlands gave it a nine out of ten uh
like i said it's platinum
action game if you're into like uh
rising revengeance yeah say the whole
thing i think he called it like a pseudo
sequel pseudo sequel yeah yeah um it's
you know it's about androids that come
back down from the moon to clear the
earth of robots to try to reclaim it for
humanity sold already sold yeah and it's
the sequel to near which was yeah like
still not totally like clear and like
how they're connected i didn't play in
here it's like
known as a cult classic but it's
it's kind of weird 2011
i believe 2010.
earlier than that yeah i think it's
earlier than that like 2009 i'm just i'm
just going to keep counting down
1972
but anyway
uh pete you played a little bit of it
there yeah there's a problem with a bug
where
the playstation menu
would say it was done installing and
downloading so you would go to play it
and then you beat this like maybe hour
long intro and then it'll go to this
menu screen and said it's not done
downloading but you also to save in this
game from like the few hours i played
you need to be around these certain
modules
and
if you're not you can't save it so then
at that point you either have to restart
the game once it's finished installing
and you lose all that progress that was
me yeah that happened but i should say
there's a patch that i chose not to
install before i started playing no nice
so that's my fault why did you why
because i literally had like a few hours
to play and i was like i want to because
he was eating possible what those pot
stickers last night right yeah you were
busy
[Music]
um this game is fun uh you kind of you
can see here if you're watching the
video
you have pods and whatnot these are kind
of affect your abilities also give you
the ranged attack but you could tell
it's that you know bayonetta uh metal
gear rising combat it's
pretty frantic heavy light attacks but
then dodging you know juggling maneuvers
and whatnot pretty stylized but the game
starts off very different from the the
footage we're looking at right now yes
it starts off you piloting essentially a
mech in flight mode uh all your comrades
get shot down and then you have to sort
of navigate like
a few scenes where you're going up
against other ships it's very much like
an old arcade shooting game you know
and that was like a really nice treat at
the beginning uh particularly because i
like that stuff and i noticed some of
the things that i borrowed uh from a
crosshatch genre which is nice to see it
was almost like the developers were like
we love shoot-em-ups we just want to do
something with this
for funsies yeah and it was a really fun
little intro
um
but the next thing that really struck me
about this game was yes the combat is
great the world is interesting to look
at the soundtrack is really good yeah
people in the chat are mentioning that
right now that's like the first thing
people mentioned they're like these like
baroque like organs going on like it
sets a really interesting tone with like
the gothic sort of outfits that the
character characters are wearing
um
yeah there's the thing that stuck out to
me the most even from before i got to
check it out even just i sit next to me
also watching him play um was that this
game has so much style yeah uh from the
ui which i actually really love the ui
it's gorgeous it looks like metal gear
yeah like even regular metal gear games
yeah which like i don't normally i mean
i care about a bad ui more than i care
about a good ui you know um but i think
it's really really beautiful um but also
just the the style like she's very chic
i love her outfit um there's even a
very cheeky if you will trophy
[Music]
looking up her skirt um because people
were kind of uh complaining about her
outfit but i would cosplay it it's
awesome um but on top of that i mean you
can see here like she
uh her style
um
transcends just her outfit and goes into
the way she moves and and the movement
um really stuck out to me as well uh
archangel 3371 and the twitch chat was
asking me does this have a new game plus
mode uh one thing miguel liked about it
was that you can oh i'm almost spoiling
things aren't i no there are multiple
endings yeah you can play see it from
different perspectives like uh what's
the rashomon sure which is like i think
the first way to do that but i i'm kind
of exasperated because
i knew there were multiple endings and i
heard people throw in like four or five
or whatever five i think 26. 26. one for
each letter of the alphabet
in wait and i thought there were five
multiple endings in here i just said
there are 26 multiple lines really
that's
but you can also like yeah you see
things from different perspectives
because you're being your 2b and a lot
of the footage you're watching now but
then you also have a 9s 9s was your the
character boy but
what you're you're boy oh that's two
beats boy to be or not to be boy we
have to spell a boi i should you guys
need to cut me off when i go into dumb
jokes like that i i really like how this
game shifts like you mentioned p uh from
like a bullet hell to this top down kind
of almost sometimes isometric but then
it becomes this side-scrolling
platformer at some points yeah the
camera itself obviously action games
kind of live and die by their camera and
in this game you see this right here
you're like piloting your mech form yeah
it switches really well between them
then you hear the top down view right
here he's a good timing on our gameplay
he's like a twin stick shooter sure yeah
you'd think it would be overwhelming but
it's not
yeah like you get a especially with the
and i take exception with the term
bullet hell if if i may
it's a very specific genre of shoot em
up and this one doesn't quite hit that
but it is still kind of frantic but you
do have the ability to chop down the
bullets that are coming at you with your
sword so unlike most uh shooting games
where you have to simply dodge them yeah
uh now you get a chance to actually like
blow them away and like a few games in
the genre had done um
it it seemed for a minute because the
ship you had would like to transfer
between like black and white i was like
oh are they going to bring economic
mechanics into this but that sadly did
not come to pass well maybe it will i'm
only
you know an hour into the game oh it's
so stylish i love it harajuku in the
future yeah miguel who had reviewed it
and he was saying one of his most
positive takeaways was uh the story it's
uh yokotaro the director who's kind of
known for his weird stylized worlds did
the first near uh that's still very much
present here despite the fact that
platinum worked on the action segments
uh these robots are kind of cute
the ones that you're fighting the whole
time yeah they look dumb they look very
endearingly dumb but even yeah even
within the first hour they they ramp up
in an interesting way it's not like
necessarily novel but very rapidly the
game is like okay these guys only have
melee attacks now they have malian range
attacks now they're wearing armor or
like now you know it's they keep ramping
up the difficulty and the variables you
get to juggle very quickly
yeah a lot of people are mentioning
platinum games kind of needed this yes
yes because what about tmnt was the last
one they released yeah they're i mean
stuff is always kind of weird
transformers is the only one that really
struck a chord with people and even then
it was like yes because it's a basic
game and it does the basics fine
um but it's been a while since they've
had their own
game really sure yeah but yeah this game
is fun i've only played
if there's 26 different endings i've
only played
like one
50 second of this game like
what that's what some of the endings i
think that's counted for like two too
big
by the way you die or like if you do
have one play through
no that's yeah so like i got an ending
technically because i died so when you
die the game starts to scroll the
credits
yeah yeah and it like goes right through
them right and so there's there's a lot
of like weird you know quote-unquote
endings but
even within that like
there's one i'd love to spoil this
morning it's not really story related
it's almost like a surprising mechanic
the ending introduces
um yeah there's just a lot of unexpected
things to come across
uh
during the game but then also after you
finish it yeah i feel like i'll get
really into the weeds with it a bit
later on because there's just so much
competing for my attention right now but
i'm seriously obsessed with her dr like
her outfit i can't stop thinking about
it and that makes me want to play it on
top of everything else i don't think
they ever really bother from what miguel
was saying to justify why
the androids are dressed like that
because yokotaro just wanted him i don't
know
yeah i know he literally i think went on
twitter and was like people are
complaining about her but send me all
your butt fan art
like he's just kind of a yeah no
apologies like this this is what i like
so what do i do go find that later yeah
so between uh their license games and
their kind of recent
uh
failures and then scalebomb being
canceled this is good for platinum games
i would say uh having worked on the
action parts of near automata so if you
want to go uh read deeper into it miguel
concepcion's review is up on gamespot
again he gave it a 9 out of 10. uh that
game is out now so go play it it's very
good if you don't have anything else to
play which you probably do but uh yeah
not to take away from near automata but
go check that out and then uh you know
leave your comments in the review leave
your comments on this video if you're
watching this on youtube or gamespot
after the fact and let us know what you
think about it
cool
all right we're gonna get into zelda a
little later in the show
because
there's a lot to talk about with that
game and i don't know when we'll ever
run out of things talk about that game
it's one of the reasons we like that
game uh but
you know we want to be fair and talk
about all the other things that are on
the switch or coming out on the switch
because let's be fair let's be fair
let's be fair let's be fair uh zelda is
not the only thing on the switch right
now and it's not the only thing that's
coming out on the switch this year
thank god um we want to talk about our
favorite current or upcoming
nintendo switch games or most
anticipated upcoming nintendo switch
games kelly i'll start with you because
you seem excited i'm so excited so give
me your first one one that i cannot wait
to play on switch is starde valley it is
coming to switch um one of the many
indie games uh nintendo actually has a
really surprising um like a surprisingly
robust uh selection of indie titles
coming up to nintendo switch i'm sorry
nindy nindy's excuse me um but when i
first played i mean sturdy valley is one
of my favorite games of 2016. i really
love it and uh
when i was playing it i just was always
thinking i want to play this in bed like
this is so relaxing and uh i have a desk
i have a gaming pc so i wasn't gonna
play it in bed um yeah the first time i
played it was when i had like a very
very high fever and i played it for like
12 hours and didn't remember anything it
looks like she's got a high fever in
this video yeah
she's sick
mary kish former games
[Laughter]
it's funnier if you know how much she
played this game mary kish former game
spot producer played a lot of stardew
valley i think it was like her number
two game last year and it was her first
and last review for us yes yeah so
she came in went out with a bang i guess
while this game's not really
explosions i went home every day for
several weeks and played this and i
think in a month i logged 160 hours um
which is a lot yeah and what did you do
that month i went to work and that's it
i forgot to eat i actually forgot to eat
dinner playing this game for a month for
not no not for the entire month um but i
just think it's uh the game the gameplay
is really suited uh to the switch and
i'm i know like i already own this i
will buy it again for switch and if you
uh haven't played stardew valley yet i
think if you have a switch it might be a
really great place to play it can't
guarantee that though because i don't
know if the control screen is weird um
but i would say
that might be having it portable and
being able to just kind of play a day or
two at a time would be awesome do you
mean you don't know if like it is mapped
well to the switch the controls yeah i
mean like i can't guarantee that the
switch version is gonna be great uh the
console versions did have a few control
hiccups if i remember correctly or some
other hiccups um there was like a saving
problem on xbox one um i miss i mean so
i can't guarantee anything but i would
say the switch is a really good uh
platform to try it out on and hopefully
the touch screen helps i think alleviate
some of those issues yeah especially
because when it you know it's designed
for pc inventory management is much
easier with a mouse and keyboard
um but yeah i think that's a good point
i think touchscreen will help too there
was going to be a vita port back in the
day and it was canceled right so this is
kind of like the spiritual successor to
the vita porn
switch is almost the spiritual successor
to the vita yeah i think yeah in a lot
of ways pete what uh what switch game
are you or are you going to be excited
about
uh i'm excited about a few things uh
a couple games which are well one of
them is just a port i am setsuna which
was rpg from tokyo rpg factory uh very
reminiscent of chrono trigger
and has sort of like a very sorrowful
story and i started playing that again
the other day and uh that game is still
good it's still a good rpg it's not
amazing but i'm glad to have an excuse
to maybe play it again in my off time um
also uh fast rmx which is
almost a port of fast racing neo from
wii but it adds in a few new tracks and
stuff like that
that is like a great amalgamation of
conceits from f-zero and the wipeout
racing games
both two series that aren't really
there's nothing really coming out in
either one of those so this is like a
wonderful little taste of those types of
games they're really fast racing games
um and then i've also been enjoying uh
from the japanese eshop which is super
easy to sign into and use uh ports of
neo geo arcade games these are not under
the virtual console umbrella
but they are they're just called arcade
classics from hamster corp whose does a
lot of the same things on playstation 4.
called what court hamster corp okay um
they've actually been very successful uh
over the past couple years like it's
it's kind of a cool story um
yeah you've got king of fighters 98
you've got waka waku seven which is a
more ridiculous fighting game than king
of fighters uh shock troopers two and
metal slug three uh and those are fun to
play played metal slug those are fun
these games are fun and it works really
well on switch
um i will say the color seems a little
bit washed out which is kind of strange
um but you can kind of get past that
because the action is so good yeah um so
if you have you have an itch for those
uh i recommend it especially king of
fighters 98 metal slug those are two
really good ones to pick up i've never
played a king of fighters game
um more complex in street fighter
huge rosters um
very interesting sprite work very like
complex shading and backgrounds and
stuff like that cool it's a fun it's a
fun difficult series sam park sharma on
the youtube chat was saying stardew
valley was not cancelled on the vita
they just kind of haven't released it
yet
right so i guess i don't know maybe i
don't know maybe that'd be funny if like
today they're like yeah we officially
canceled it
no i mean that'd be great if it came to
vida i mean
games should live wherever they can yeah
i
think
uh kelly you were talking about tumble
seed yeah so uh during gdc i did go to
an indies event um and goddamn it
stay on message
[Laughter]
there were several games there that i
really enjoyed playing and the stand out
for me was tumble seed um which is uh
they describe it as a roly
um and basically you're this cute little
seat it's deceptively cute um you're
so you roll on this tree branch um and
you can see it kind of in action there
but it's super super hard i played it
for
probably 45 minutes with joey um and he
and i had a lot of trouble even
ascending the mountain so basically what
you're doing is you're trying to climb
up this mountain without falling into
those holes and you have to manage a lot
at once so you have to figuratively and
literally balance um everything you're
doing there's lots of different powers
and um
yeah so you can like plant a flag and
that's your checkpoint or you can put
thorns on your body oh that was very
good timing um
and i was just i couldn't stop playing i
had so much fun with it i can't it's
coming out in spring um and if you want
a full roundup of indies from gdc we
have that on the site right now
go check that out wait so
does it use like the gyro scope and the
or gyro yeah
the hero scope um i played just with the
the analog sticks
just because i it was it would be way
too hard to play with the
motion controls one of those games it
seems uh kind of deceivingly simple yeah
it looks it looks very simple it's very
charming art um and it was
punishingly difficult really yeah okay
so the article that you put up has about
13 games that look great and i think
there are 64 like 54 games that they
announced indie games so the switch is
going to get a pretty nice injection of
stuff yeah i think that's all supposed
to be this year right oh yeah most of
the stuff they showed was this year
there's like snake pass which is uh that
looks very interesting very interesting
platformer where you're a snake and you
have to slither um so the movement is
really unique like you don't make you
don't like move and jump you kind of
like work your way you like corkscrew
your way around things yeah you're gonna
hate it it's like when i'm drunk
[Laughter]
um but yeah if you want to check that
out we have a list of 13 coolest games
you've ever heard of um and it's not at
all all of the games that are there um
and so i'm very excited though those are
all like
soon to release yes most of it is
and it's also not just nintendo switch
games on that list um but the ones we
saw celeste which is this really hard
platformer that was awesome um
and then a graceful explosion machine
which is a an arcade shooter that i
really liked and it's also gorgeous
so awesome
have you played snipperclips yet no i
want to play it so bad looks fun i've
like i've touched it for like a couple
seconds at an event not enough to get an
impression it keeps coming up because
that's the one that people are saying it
makes
like good use of the joy cons at least
or it kind of shows how you can play
cooperatively with the joy cons yeah
yeah yeah i don't know i haven't touched
it yet yeah it looks good a friend whose
wife doesn't play a lot of games and
they were up until like 4am playing
snipperclips together i will snip you
no
no i think you have to like cut like
shapes out of each other to then satisfy
like objectives like in a you know a
wholesome game yeah
very good family game bomberman have you
played it mm-hmm no rob henry's been he
played a little bit a little bit yeah
hey look bomberman 64 was really fun
this is a very different game i know
bomberman 64 was what like
99
97.
i don't know but here we go
clearly we've established that you don't
know years
wait no uh the first year was 2010 by
the way so i was i was right the second
time um yeah you're looking at bomberman
here right now yeah i just might have
been uh here's justin nick and chastity
playing uh reviewer jason dapreel gave
it a seven on game spot it's a good game
for him um i think
this game requires a little bit of
nostalgia and you know really
understanding what you're getting
yourself into because it's not a really
complex game but it's certainly one of
those things that works great when you
have multiple people to play against
um that said there is like a single
player mode you know with some story
stuff but yeah from what i've heard
about one two switch and how it's
supposedly designed to be a party game
but you kind of have to
be quiet kelly you were talking about
this i played it at a party uh with a
ton of uh my loudest friends everyone
was drunk and we had to continually tell
each other to shut up and it basically
killed the mood and then we had to play
baby the one where you rocked the baby
and literally everyone left the room
except the person who had to hold the
baby well i don't want to confront being
an adult i'm out of here yeah everyone
was like time to pour another drink um
and so there are some games like i think
the milking one you don't need sound and
that is a hit because of the uh obvious
uh giggling that happens
uh watching rob plays i really didn't
like that wizard game i didn't get that
i didn't like wizard oh the baseball one
sucks
hate the baseball one sir yeah the
tennis was difficult as well because
it's like audio it's like
that nintendo treehouse rep looks really
boring until now well so i like crystal
a lot yeah no yes they're both great you
just have to like really listen for like
the sound the ball makes so if you're
focused on your opponent at all you're
kind of like
gonna lose it was very fun um i think
the the only one that's really good for
a party is the soda shaking one because
you have to look in each other's
eyes as you shake the joy-con in a
certain manner uh the camera's not on us
right now but i'm sure you can imagine
um
and um there were a lot of laughs to be
had about that one yeah um
i do do want to say uh just speaking of
this kind of this switch stream watching
justin haywald do just dance was the
highlight of my whole life
oh he is he was talented chastity
actually like is a good dancer but
justin surprised everyone
so we also it's clear we also when at
the same party when we were playing one
two switch we eventually switched to
just dance
because we were like well you know just
dance we can
like everyone will be listening to the
music we don't have to tell each other
to be quiet um and and that was a much
better party game actually for drunk
people
what about blaster master zero people
saying it releases tomorrow
yeah miguel really liked that yeah
played it yeah it's on the japanese shop
you can get it now like okay yeah and it
is japanese shop is easy to access
yeah you can se you create an account
very easily you just set your region to
japan um
there's a few websites where you can go
to buy eshop points to spend the
japanese store and you'll just get an
email right away with a code uh to
redeem um yeah blaster master zero is a
return to the classic blaster master
formula there's been a couple weird
sequels for that game
but you sort of you ride in a tank then
you can hop out and you're also a little
guy it's very much a nostalgic game but
the cool thing about it uh that
makes me feel like it's got some promise
it's made by integrates um the team that
yes they worked on mighty number nine
but that was not their baby uh azure
striker gunvault is really what they've
been working on the past few years and
that is an amazing uh not really a
spin-off but like it takes the mega man
x formula and runs with it with some new
mechanics super fast platforming great
action and they have they have a good
ear for music as well so i think blast
master zero though a little stiff
might actually just have some some cool
elements within it cool uh before we
wrap up this segment kelly you said you
really wanted to talk about mario kart
yeah i
am very excited because a lot of people
didn't know this and i was talking to
people about how excited i am for mario
kart 8 deluxe because it adds double
dash mechanics oh wow she was a really
good mario kart yeah yeah which was like
you know
a lot of people say it's the best mario
kart apex yeah you don't have to pick
between waluigi and wario anymore you
just get both just you can get both of
those dudes
stop what you're doing what am i doing
look at indies
waluigi all the way
waluigi mario
[Laughter]
are you guys do you really like waluigi
i i'm a wario guy oh no i hate wario
waluigi's waluigi is the boy
um
but yeah so that you can uh hold two
items in one once and switch uh
presumably switch um who's driving um
from what i understand and i'm so
excited about that yeah i'm looking
forward to that and then just uh to wrap
it up quick
to triple a that we didn't mention
whether we're uh super mario odyssey
which looks like grand theft auto mixed
with mario 64. which is only because of
the city right it doesn't look like
jesus
but it's an easy way for them to like
extend the mario character some way
without actually introducing a new
character for us to get over the
avengers are gonna the helicarrier is
gonna come down in new york and mario's
gonna have to
solve that yeah
so that's nice thank you yeah it's good
um and then in terms of other aaa
releases on the switch
i'm missing one that arms
yeah i don't know if you call that
triple a no
first party game i i guess do you want
to talk about arms now that you brought
it up
i must do it
sorry splatoon 2. splatoon
i knew there was one in my head and i
completely forgot about it but pete
please regale us about arms arms is a
very quirky sort of one-on-one fighting
game what was it sorry i am confusing
jean-luc yeah let's talk about splatoon
just threw up some footage uh i'm pretty
pumped for this actually i played the
first one a little bit finally like
three months ago uh i did not own a wii
u for a long time and then i played it
and i like shooters a lot and this is a
very inventive uh franchise i'm excited
to bring in the second one the
presentation at the switch
stream was awesome the dude came on it
was posing with the dual pistols but a
lot of people thought this was just a
port but then like oh they're adding a
lot of new stuff but yeah it's a sequel
i adore splatoon i hope that cali makes
a reappearance because i was always
always excited there's never a character
who has my name um same here i don't
know my glasses on but
archangel three three seven one i think
that's what it says i squint hard enough
xenoblade two oh yeah incredibly excited
for that i i love the first two
xenoblade games
and monolithsoft helped out a little bit
with breath of the wild's open world
i
i hope that like
there's some sort of quid pro quo thing
where nintendo's gonna like give them a
hand in some department i don't know
probably not going to happen either way
really looking forward to that one
that's good shout out cool and then arms
yes all right awesome so those are our
most anticipated uh switch games coming
out this year or they're already on the
switch apart from zelda which we're
going to get into shortly
uh kelly
i'm gonna
the first time i think i have to boot
you off the lobby we're gonna bring uh
serious regular rob handler i kind of
wish we didn't have to oh yeah me too oh
i like you more than rob i like rob
ruff's cool all right he smells nice
what are you uh what are you doing the
rest today uh working on zelda stuff
as i think a lot of us are yeah so you
get to talk about zelda i'm gonna write
about zelda
all right i'll take that deal all right
bye thanks kelly
bring on rob hanley i'm gonna roboto
uh yeah if you're just joining in
youtube or twitch chats uh we are gonna
get into shadow of war right now there's
a new 16-minute gameplay
video out that we watched and i'm pretty
excited about and then we're going to
get into zelda later on the show
uh rob handler what's up what's up great
to be here how have you been super duper
she's been playing zelda a lot that's
all i've been talking about yeah a lot
of zelda yeah it's not we're going to
talk about now though first people in
this chat are asking we're going to talk
about shadow of war
we talked about it a couple weeks ago we
didn't really know much about it so uh
i pretty much just talked a lot which i
do pretty well sometimes not well but a
lot of but now we actually have stuff to
talk about so lucky you in the chat and
uh watching this on youtube or twitch or
gamespot we
watched shadowvoir have a much better
understanding of what it is rob you
played a lot of shadow of mordor yeah um
from your perspective someone who played
a lot of that game back in 2014
what are you excited most about based on
the 60 minutes of gameplay from shadow
four uh the one thing that stood out for
me was you know like the first game you
can recruit
uh war chiefs and such to be on your
side but this time around it feels like
you get to
kind of see them on the field and
actually like
watch your your team that you've created
your your
uh yeah your war like and unfold that
you have basically shifted yourself yeah
and and
the last game kind of had that
but it was only in the last few moments
right where you actually got to see your
your entire game like unfold yeah when
you did this like storming they're like
these checker there are kind of these
you know like trees screens where you
see where your different lieutenants are
kind of ranking up where your spies are
and then how they're gonna usurp the
next person now you're actually building
an army
yeah and you get to actually see it in
action opposed to uh god it's been so
long since i've played the the shadow
mortar
2014 it's crazy i think but
um you're you know in that one you're
kind of looking at a menu the whole time
and you're seeing like a chess play of
of
you know
figures moving around a board but now
you get to like see that on the
battlefield or at least i hope so so the
60 minute gameplay video showed one of
these invasions uh into the fortress so
there are several fortresses so here's
sarah goss these are actual real i
almost said real world real middle-earth
locations uh you know you have keurig
thundel minutes morgle australia you
have it looks like based on the video
what are you smirking about i like lord
of the rings i know but i just love your
memory for everything you ever encounter
you you just you i read lord of the
rings a lot it doesn't matter anything i
throw at you you anyway yeah uh it looks
like based on the video the very end it
looks like your ultimate goal is to get
to berador the
tower where sauron resides because he's
coming back to power the premise of the
game is that tally and the ranger and
keller brimbore the elf who's famous in
the books for like having crafted the
ring of power you're making your own and
i don't know they didn't really clarify
whether
the ring was factoring into your
abilities yet at this point in the game
but it looks like the combat is still
very much intact from shadow mordor it's
that you know kind of arkham asylum
popularized the attack and counter
uh dichotomy of combat but now
some of the abilities they showed
i don't know if this was just later on
in the skill tree for the purposes of
this
demo but they were just executing people
left and right and my favorite one which
we might see i'll hold off actually i'll
wait so we're gonna see it but you're
like warping around you're shooting an
arrow and then warping to where the
arrow landed but i keep telling people i
don't know if there are many x-com fans
but this reminds me of x-com in the way
that there's this strategy layer above
the meat of the game kind of because
you're still coming in and fighting this
combat and supposedly the different
regions of mordor
still have these open worlds where
you're exploring and like rob said you
know you're doing the nemesis system and
going to different outposts uh taking
control of different lieutenants uh you
know kind of planting seeds for the
you know
interior destruction of this battalion
but then later on you are actually like
you can see here assaulting these
fortresses to take over the regions and
then build your army whether it be
through like supplies or pillaging or
getting new recruits or war machines
it's actually the strategy layer of
building your army with the final
endgame of getting to sauron and in here
it looked like uh i mean it look looks
like you can recruit those bigger ogres
i don't know the name of trolls trolls
thank you
yes uh those guys uh clearly are you
know
stronger and you can imagine hey i'm
gonna use uh this troll to
be my front lines um
you know door smasher
yeah you'll see that shortly yeah and
you know as you can imagine if you lose
him well shoot now i gotta go find
another one of those guys like you are
strategizing your your your team and
moving those pieces
uh more so or i mean
not at all from the first game sure
all the orcs were generally the same
they just had you know different
personalities and kind of you know
procedurally generated
uh but yeah and the other thing i think
i'm excited about with this is
um not that i would ever want to be
friends with an orc
but
there's that option right like you can
kind of pick favorites and and have them
climb up in the ranks
and on the flip you know later on uh
in this uh demo that i thought was
really awesome was when you know you're
you're battling the end
uh overlord boss
and one of your buddies comes in and and
saves the day yeah and helps you out
yeah afterwards you have the option to
appoint him as the new overlord of the
stronghold hold
or you don't yeah and i and then this
one in the demo they did you know he's
like hey this guy saved my life i'm
gonna reward him he's now overlord what
if he didn't and then later on as the
game implies
he betrays you because you didn't oh i
wasn't fit to be a leader
yeah second number two peter campbell of
shadow of war that's really cool to me
and then later on in the game that was
the coolest part about the nemesis
system was did you get that reference no
i peter campbell from mad men never mind
no yep you remember everything
non-sequitur uh you know and then later
on this guy
just betrays you yeah
and then he's like i
no i'm the leader of the other guys like
you know let's fight yeah because that's
fine
monolith there's like a voice over by
someone that sounds suspiciously like
kate blanchette i don't think it is it's
not i don't know why i said i don't
think it is because i know it's not but
it sounds like her sound like it just
reminds me of the voice over intro the
beginning of fellowship of the ring when
uh galadriel is like uh
you know things are changing and whatnot
but she says specifically that there is
you know friendship is a major component
of the nemesis system now right here i
love this assassination watch this
talion comes out or no sorry calibrimbor
comes out of his body kills the other
one does this co-op take down and then
goes back into his body and then this
one too right here right here and then
this is as opposed to shooting an arrow
and spawning near the guy he does the
flip
come to me
yeah
yeah that's what we need god i forgot
how satisfying it is to get off an orc's
head
the second a lot going on this game or
second or two i saw that i was like oh
yeah that's this game i forgot so i
you know based on stuff last week you
guys know i didn't really play a whole
lot of the first one yeah but seeing
this i now want to go back and play that
so that you can come into this like
as armed as you guys are with knowledge
and excitement because this does look
really cool and i know
outside of this we're going to have the
stuff that was in the you know the core
of the first game at least i hope so
yeah like this this seems like another
one of those experiences that is just
different and like meaningfully
different in like a big way yeah the
whole you know
angle that they're trying to go for is
that they're expanding the nemesis
system to not just be about these enemy
leaders but bam you have a spy that
you've had a few months in here and he's
just been planted and he happens to be a
sniper who saves you but yeah
uh look at how many things he's immune
to this dude seems badass but also
immune to execution i think if you're
listening to the audio or when you
listen to audio i encourage you to watch
this gameplay video with audio after the
lobby if you have not seen it yet this
is when she brings up the friendship and
i think again because maybe because you
had a high friendship rating kind of a
la mass effect or something he saved you
here i don't know that you actually
would have died permanently or died
right there but he [ __ ] smokes this
dude when he comes back um we're about
to see kind of how the strongholds can
change based on the enemies uh in a
little bit but here's the big one the
gear system there were uh aesthetic new
outfits but you just got this like
rohirum outfit which looks so [ __ ]
sick oh my god
watch you're sorry
yeah uh it looks kind of like if you're
like super in-depth the man's face can
we get a more interesting looking person
no what it's not a not like an
aragorn-esque guy no no he's just so
plain
i'm not i can't be the only one who
looks at that and i'm like that's the
most generic face i've ever seen i
probably thought that back in 2014
no i don't i don't
necessarily like him i just keep
thinking about how funny it is to
imagine like this guy this human hanging
out with orcs day and night making
friends
i'd get pretty frustrated if i was him
like i'd like to see someone like stress
wrinkles on his feet yeah
gray hair yeah yeah you see a human
people are bringing up the swear jar
i'll put money into it after
the show ends we have to bring it back
to keep this up yeah you just give me
that um yeah but the gear system is
actually affecting your abilities now
but here's this dude the demolisher he's
not immune to fire which i say that
specifically because you get onto a warg
soon right here and when you're mounted
you are but you're demolisher he's dead
i like this down like it's like oh great
now i got to find another troll right
but your other lieutenant that they
brought they showed at the beginning
which this becomes important later on
the demo
he's immune to fire uh and if you guys
saw on the menu when you were when they
were planning on attacking this
stronghold it showed that the boss has
like flame attacks and weapons
uh that comes into play here but also
you can see something about to happen
right here so you cannot just ride wargs
you can ride and we'll swore again
dragons
uh this looks like lair do you remember
that game yeah yeah this i it's
not too much in common but just like the
dragon mechanics look similar
that's about where it starts yeah this
looks
really fun
yeah i mean you know that dragon what
else no
i can't
you're just raining down fire like
imagine like if the witch king comes at
you on his nostril and you're
just in an aerial battle kind of like a
dragon ball z thing between a wyvern and
uh
that that screech
that like yeah
we got the boss battle coming up but
yeah i'm interested in how this game is
gonna combine the open world and combat
mechanics with the overarching strategy
layer because they kind of describe it
but they don't really show it in
execution too much they say that once
you take over this
fortress you will
that fortress will be the hub for that
region and it'll be depending on the
overlord you put in place to govern it
that'll he'll dictate whether you get
new recruits for your army or
new supplies or maybe like new war
machines but here you see he's about to
take over this two guy with his he's
freaking out cause he just showed up on
a dragon
and you're controlling his mind so you
get him and so yeah yes no problem
i'm on your side yes that's cool let's
please get your thumb out of my eyes
so now he's uh you just recruited him
he's gonna help fight for you all of a
sudden and of course now you're coming
up to the final overlord boss battle
which is pretty cool this show is how
the nemesis system affects the
strongholds soon and uh
slow walk-in yeah i wish i really hope
that's slowly in video i really hope uh
compared to the first game that there is
um a lot more diversity in terrain in in
areas opposed to what the first game
just had like two you know had like the
typical igneous rock of mordor and then
that kind of lush region yeah but barely
barely yeah so here we go uh again the
narrator is talking about how depending
on what overlord there is this boss
fight arena will be different this dude
favors fire attacks and
obviously you could see he's this
massive trolls but he's got these like
two podiums in either two pillars on
either side of them that become these
flamethrowers but
this boss fight plays out differently
depending on their preferences and their
abilities so this dude is very much into
like flame-based combat so that factors
into this boss fight arena which is
super cool because that actually affects
the strongholds not just the characters
i really want to know how
many strongholds do you see in a single
playthrough how limited is it or yeah i
mean because if this is like you know
generated through like some sort of
algorithm or whatever and there's like a
lot of them like this is really
impressive but i have to imagine that
outside of the boss arenas a lot of
these are going to have to be handmade
yeah unless they somehow manage to just
generate them
so they do in the in for the first game
i definitely
i forgot at what point but toward the
later uh
parts of the game i was seeing like
similar guys
as far as warchiefs yeah like oh you
wait i've seen you before you sort of
like defined enough variables that the
game just doesn't really yeah have any
grounds
yeah and and that was like
you know a little not disheartening but
it was like hey wait i didn't i kill you
and you're back yeah um so i'm
interested to see how they do that
because again they're you know they talk
about each
orc warchief uh having a different story
right bringing their own like story to
the table
like emergent gameplay as it were yeah
i'm curious to know to what extent will
that be right yeah uh earlier today
grant wilson on twitter was saying do
you think shadow of war risks alienating
players the first game with this new
tower defense style fortress system uh
i don't think it's like tower defense
but i get what he's saying and that's
kind of what i was just wondering how
much like the first game will just be if
you liked it with the open world and the
combat like how is it going to factor
into this overarching strategy layer
because they show how it implements into
the combat but they don't show too much
of the actual strategy like ui and
whatnot we got two fans right right here
i mean would you want a second game that
was functionally similar to the first
one and
you know just with the narrative being
different
i mean i i would like that but no i like
i think yeah like rob you and i were
talking about yesterday this seems like
it's like a full-on sequel uh in the
sense that it's you know changing things
up so right
i don't i think it risks alienating
players in the first game but i'm
excited for it as a huge fan of the
first game that was my game of the year
in 2014. i'm really excited for this
even outside like the lord of the rings
fan service i can't wait this seems like
again xcom2 is one of my favorite games
last year and this isn't a turn-based
strategy game but there's still that
dichotomy between the strategy and the
actual up close action which
really excites me i um i'm trying to
think of a game that that had a similar
like region control
mechanic of
where i got it annoying in this game i'm
speaking of is is oh great my fortress
is being attacked again so i have to
fall back to this fortress
and
spend it when i'm already trying to
advance
in discovering or exploration was it
like max
no i know what you're talking about
there was this game and i can't think of
it where it was like you kept oh i had
to go back and defend it uh there were
it was an assassin's creed there was an
assassin's creed games did that uh
assassin's creed 4 black flag you kind
of came up on strongholds like this but
then in like earlier and i think
brotherhood or revelations was it it was
revelations i'm thinking of when you
have to do that tower defense stuff and
it was awful but after a while you
realize you don't even need to worry
about those strongholds but that's what
i'm thinking of at least and and here
they're talking about you know you
appoint this uh guy here who um his what
his his stronghold perk is that he will
pillage
um
the area and bring in more resources so
if
if i have to like you know i mean like
if my
intake of resources is now being
diminished because i have to go back and
like
you know defend this like castle i'm
being distracted and i don't know if i
want
so much for that someone in the chat
might is it just fallout 4
yeah i think that might have been
how often it would pop up and i would
say forget it yeah you just you're
screwed right for settlers sorry i did
my part
uh i'm a lone wanderer alec brynnard
earlier on twitter also had a question
uh
he asked if we think expanding a nemesis
system is enough as general gameplay
doesn't seem too altered uh based on the
depth they're going for with this or
would it appear they're going for in
this game what releases in august right
it's not too far out it's yeah dude it's
what it's going to be close to five
months away less than six months away uh
yeah i'm super excited for this game i
think they're it looks like they're
doing enough to make like an actual
sequel not just like an iteration on the
first game yeah pumped for yeah i mean
it makes sense like the last game like
you just you know you built your army
and you did you know just a minimal uh
attack with them and here it's like hey
you still have this army that you just
you know created and now you're like
waging war
shadow of war yes
i'm super excited for this game uh if
you haven't watched it yet we
have that 16 minute gameplay video up on
gamespot i encourage you to go watch it
you just saw
the entirety of it we just watched we
watched we watched quite a lot of it but
yeah you can see how attacking these
strongholds works uh you can go watch
that entire gameplay video we do have
kind of we had a lot of segment a couple
weeks ago about what we wanted but now
we know much more about the game uh if
you want to go back to 2014 and read a
review i don't know who reviewed that
game maybe it was kevin van orden
uh yeah shadow of mordor is worth
getting back into if like you have a
lull from zelda or near or mass effect
which is coming out in a couple weeks go
try uh shadow mordor out highly
encourage it
uh but other than that let us know what
you think of the 16 minutes of gameplay
if you're as excited as rob and i are
and pete based on what you saw not
having to play the first game too much
i'm excited
so let us know what you think
cool
uh
we don't have really much else to talk
about oh uh did you guys ever play uh
breath of the wild back in the day
that was my
segway
uh
i'm almost 100 hours into the game would
you you gave it a 10 out of 10. gave it
a 10 out of 10. i almost punched
everything
diaz brown
it's the second 10 i've ever given and i
think it what was the first one uh
solid five shadow of mordor yeah metal
gear solid five which you seem to like
certain kind of game a lot open world
emerging
like those two gamepl you can't really
compare them but you can't you kind of
can in a way and i think it's because uh
one of the things that just makes zelda
so special and i think is leading into
what we're going to talk about is just
the the myriad ways that you can uh
tackle any situation whether it's just
simply movement or it's like dealing
with combat or puzzle solving and metal
gear had a lot of that as well but there
are so many more rules and options at
play in zelda even though
on the surface it looks like a far
simpler game right metal gear you're
just scrolling through okay how many
weapons do i have like these different
vantage points like okay you know troops
doesn't matter zelda is is by far the
more complex game um
but it's because you don't feel the
weight of that complexity that it's so
nice and so refreshing and innovative
and yeah
for me certainly
makes me think about how i'm scoring
games now differently yeah maybe it's
the art style or maybe it is the
sense of calm you get in some parts of
this hyrule but
it really does seem simple sometimes but
then yeah you see stuff like this
hitting a bee's nest uh to drive these
guys out so you can go get their weapons
so they can't pick them up so you can
attack them much easier those bees are
gonna chase you too yeah better have
some fire get rid of them is that how
you get rid of that so i get rid of it
because there's no right way to play
right that's what i want to talk about
today is kind of how
seemingly every single person that is
talking about this game that i've talked
to of like 25 people
is having a vastly different experience
right from the beginning you start off
on you know i don't know how
that's the thing with this game spoilers
aren't really narrative
spoilers i mean there are but this game
it's tough to talk about all the things
you're seeing because you don't want
some the best part is how you stumble
upon these things but i can't bring
myself to tweet about this game because
i feel like even showcasing a weapon
that someone hasn't found you know i
find it 80 hours into the game i could
have found it a lot earlier but i don't
know when people are finding these
things so i don't want to rob anyone
even of the you know existence of
certain things
and it's interesting how
yeah again like not linear it is you
know the other day i think you and i are
chatting like oh did you go to
uh kakariko village like yes
okay well then you saw you must have
seen this along the way because there's
only one path to actually go right
however
but you can i think it was it was going
to the goron city you were trying to
tell me where the mines were that's when
i was like
i i'm at the north mind you're like no
the south wind like that's not on my map
what do you mean the south line and then
it's on the main road right and then you
realize yeah
you know it's just like the it's like an
exponential factor right like the more
you play the more you have just created
your own path yeah so you like you come
to terms you're like oh i must have
paraglided from here
and it's just
there are so many ways to get to said
area and
that's where like the hours uh the early
hours are so different because i was you
know rock climbing a mountain because
you know what i felt like rock climbing
well someone maybe
wanted to hit a shrine on the right side
of the map like
it's that's the early aspect of it that
is just so different for everyone yeah
one of the earlier things they were
talking about in this game is kind of
how it was following in the footsteps of
link between worlds and that you don't
have to do dungeons in a set order right
there are four major dungeons in this
game
uh structurally speaking but then there
are also like how many shrines are there
116. oh [ __ ] i think eight
sorry this game is huge uh and i've done
47 now 100 hours yeah yeah uh i went you
know like right to the zora the la neru
province province right to do my first
divine beast and
every time i go to sit down to play the
game i'm thinking oh i should there's a
shrine nearby i should do that or i
should go get this armor which a friend
told me was in this region or i should
do this but then i discovered something
new and it pulls me off the beaten path
in a way that but it's not overwhelming
and i it takes a while to try to
i couldn't put my finger on it for a
while why i love it so much but
this game you're constantly thinking
right i mean we talk about how horizon
zero dawn just released and that's a
great open world game
but zelda kind of like rewrites the
rules of what it means to be a good open
world game right i go back to horizon
i'm actually kind of bored moving
between points i see an objective marker
and the world is gorgeous and i'm moving
through this jungle then it's a desert
and i'm fighting these really cool robot
dinosaurs but
i'm not thinking the entire time like i
am in zelda zelda you see you see a
simple tree and you're saying there
could be apples on that that would help
me get through this next book goblin
camp it's the mystery and once you and
once you have
an event that happens to you in this
game where it is such a curveball blind
side like i can't believe this happened
that's when you oh you get struck by
lightning because you have a massive
two-handed sword
equipped
that's that's when you
don't feel overwhelmed but that's when
you are are getting distracted because
you see anything from a person walking
down the path to again yeah a tree with
a rock slightly to the left like
everything is so jam-packed and filled
in this world that
you just gotta do it because you also
feel like no one else has ever seen this
yeah you're inundated with possibilities
and it goes back to this idea that i've
probably said a thousand times to
youtube but this lack of control you
never ever feel in control of the world
you never feel like you understand all
of its rules or all of its possibilities
which is part and parcel of it being
mysterious right and constantly having
this sense of wonder so yes even like a
simple mountain that you climb right
like it's you know the elevation brings
one thing the weather brings another
thing like what could be on top maybe
there's treasure right but oh what's
that in the distance once you get up
there like there are things that happen
like this and a lot of open world games
including something like horizon which i
think is
not a similar game but it's the most
recent you know thing we can compare it
to
but this game just manages to to never
relent
with uh
just making you wonder like what if and
and in comparison to
a horizon which again is an awesome game
uh to even assassin's creed games with
you know icons literally littered on a
map
generally there is a point where you
know what you're gonna get
from this guy
i don't need to take on this beast
because you know what i know what he's
packing so i'm just gonna move on you're
more inclined to move on from different
situations yeah um but this game i'm
just constantly like sticking through
and then you die and you're like well
i'm coming back yeah because now it's
like personal
yeah oh i have a beef with this one
character that i ran into i won't spoil
it but could not i
maybe if i was much better at this game
i mean it's a difficult game but maybe i
could have beaten him but i'm coming
back later once i have more armor and
whatnot but these survival mechanics and
the difficulty both
i think are integral to this world
they are integral to this world because
the survival i mean like you have to the
wilderness is just as much as an enemy
this sounds cliche but hyrule is an
enemy too but it can help you but it can
also like just destroy you right it
you can go into the tundra and it's too
cold and you don't have warm enough
clothes or you haven't cooked something
that can keep you warm uh you know you
can drown if you don't i mean it's not
gonna kill you go back to the bank but
it could kill you but if you run that
stamina you could fall off a cliff take
falling damage if it's raining the rocks
will be too slick for you to climb up uh
you know the rain i think reliably
is the worst in the best possible way
and it's for me it's one of the first
games i think that like has actually
brought the meaning of rain yeah and to
full extent opposed to any other game
where it's like oh it's raining things
are a little wet yeah this is like one
it rains and it completely [ __ ]
completely i swear to god damn it i'm a
good boy
completely messes with everything
torches can't have a campfire you can't
have a hook you can't yeah you can't you
know oh you think oh maybe i can just
wait out the rain or speed it up with a
campfire well it's raining dude
yeah you're on a cliff side and it's
raining and you slip and your stamina is
at zero and then there's a river below
you're dead imagine like lightning if
you're wearing metal armor you get smoke
or you're carrying a metal bow or you
have anything metal on you but also it
it's not so systematic where it's like
okay well i know i have to wait five
minutes before the rain to pass
and you think it's gone
and then it comes back and it's
like 10 15 minutes of just rain
so we're in we're getting yelled at for
spoiling the weather factors and it's
what it's been popularized yes that's a
but i think this is a perfect example of
how everything in this game is so
freaking fascinating that even even the
things that seem so basic to us
when we first found them
right when you first discovered it it's
like wow
yeah it's hard to talk about this game
without really spoiling it because it's
it's
it's unprecedented i think what it does
another cool thing is that you had
played maybe
60 hours by the time your review went up
yeah and i played half an hour and i saw
something like a mechanic that you
didn't even know about didn't yeah
rob comes in the next day he's like when
did you find this like that's a thing
you can do like i just found out
something new last night again that
whether it's a mechanic or something
related to survival or
related to
something that i didn't even stumble on
because it was in this like cave that i
didn't go into when i was more focused
on going to coca rico before i got
pulled off the beaten path to some other
shrine
there's a lot in this game but none of
it feels like it's just there for the
sake of it it feels like it's
well i will counter your point i think
the korok seeds
those are clearly there for the sake of
it like oh yeah on the top of a mountain
you know you're gonna find it like yeah
that's the one thing to me that feels a
little bit like obvious and contrived
you know more than you know anything
else um
but it's because they're just simply
everywhere they're just simply
everywhere and every time you see
something you're like okay well i know
the developer like made this so that i
would find this thing like it's it's
it's super clear what it is it doesn't
harm the game
but it's just that one thing was like i
wonder if that could have been different
but yeah i don't care yeah because
yeah i don't want i don't want to spoil
what those do but like yeah
that is the one thing that it seems like
there's something there
just to say oh this we can fill up this
gap in the map with one of these or
something i don't know it's a small way
to reward
um like modest achievement right and
it's luckily it's quick enough you know
what i mean yeah it was sometimes
they're opposing i guess occasionally
there's some there may be longer but for
the most part
you they're simple enough to just like
easily knock out in like 10 seconds he
didn't quit yeah
um
dude just to like reiterate yeah like
before i got in here i was talking with
tay and that guy has only put in what
six hours and he told me something that
just blew my mind yeah blew my mind i
was like how did you see this was it the
skeleton thing
yeah
so well someone
last night was saying something too
yeah there's a lot in this game right
it's
it never feels overwhelming which is
weird because a lot of times open world
games even with horizon which there's
not like
you know i don't want to just say
zelda's great because there's so much to
do like i think we've already touched on
why i think it's all integral for the
most part but horizon it got
overwhelming for some reason there's not
like half the things to do in that game
and find out but like there's always
some new mechanic in zelda that
encourages you for not just exploring
the world itself but exploring how the
game works and connects you to that
world whether it's through the survival
or the difficulty that everything seems
and i'm talking to people in this game
more than i have in any other game in a
long time because they have these like
this dad will be telling a ghost story
to keep kids away from this certain spot
or this person will say oh yeah i saw
something up there and i'll read this
rune that said
oh there's there's this
hidden artifact up there that people
used to talk about but
now it's like flooded so you can't get
there
and it won't tell you where it is it'll
say where it is but it won't like put an
objective point on your map it's up to
you to put the objective point through
your chica slate scope or like or at
best look at your map and be like okay
the guy was talking about a body of
water what bodies of water are around
here yeah crap there's a bunch which
one's it going to be and then you get
there and then you just cover something
else and just like it's got a sense of
geography and moving through it that i
haven't felt in an open world game in a
long time i mean you look like grand
theft auto 5 which i think is one of the
better open world games and that makes
it feel like a real world that's lived
in that you can explore but still there
will be like 10 minute periods and i'm
just driving across los santos and i'm
turning my brain off and zelda because
of the survival or because of the fact
that there's probably something
pretty cool around the corner i never
stop
thinking and i'm never disengaged and i
say never because i've played
25 hours at this point and i still
haven't gotten bored you played 100 and
you're still not bored not even close to
bored yeah
and i the fact alone that i have over
i'm not even halfway done with the
shrines and i look at my map and i'm
like i have never explored this
huge area yeah and there's a few of
those like i'm so happy to have a game
that i already love and know that i will
continue to love for the next few weeks
yeah
i have to cut us off because i feel like
we could just talk about this forever um
we'll probably find we have a ton of
zelda i mean did you want to add
anything that we didn't say i mean i
know you do but
i love uh you know for a game obviously
it doesn't it's not like texture heavy
or intense
it feels like all that was put into
like just the breathing nature and
animations of like a bokoblin camp like
one of my favorite things i always say
is like you i just love like
looking at them and it's like you know
i think we've tired this
like comment but it's like you know six
of them and there's this one guys
it's like telling a story and everyone's
like yeah totally yeah
and then one of them will just start
dancing and he's like yeah totally in
there you know
dance party and then it's like now i'm
throwing a bomb in
like i just
you know
wildlife like just it just feels so
freaking good just like watch and
observe take photos i never thought like
well the first time they like showed
like you know linked like doing photos
and selfies and stuff
it just feels so right the char the
charm fits in i love this
god like i filled up the album i was
like oh great i got delete some of my
favorites
but you get to keep them if they're
added to the compendium yeah so you can
go back there yeah but just not pretty
photos right yeah
man i
want to play this right now um yeah so i
guess we'll cut it off there but uh
i would invite you to share your zelda
stories in the comments but obviously
like try not to spoil anything but like
hit us up if you want on twitter and let
us know like but don't spoil anything
it's such a weird game
i made the mistake of uh using google to
look up one thing yesterday for the
first time and i immediately regretted
it yeah it's
it kind of sucked it was it actually was
the exact thing that i expected that
would happen from the thing i was
looking up but to just even have that
confirmed was like damn it i just robbed
myself of this like
don't do it
don't do it
god this is just so hard to talk about
this game now it's so great all right
well so that is the end of that segment
and uh getting closer to our show but
let us know what you think about zelda
breath of the wild how are you playing
it what are some of the
what are some of the directions you took
when you left the early part of the game
uh let us know without spoiling too much
uh leaving the comments but again
try not to spoil it too much but yeah
let us know what you think about breath
of the wild pete gave it a 10 out of 10
on game spot we have a ton of coverage
up we have guides if you're into that uh
if you don't want to discover certain
things for yourself or if you just want
some things kind of more illuminated for
you uh we have some helpful guides up
from a bunch of our editors we also have
uh
something starting tomorrow that you two
are excited about pete and rob you'll be
called the triforce and uh i had pete
described earlier rob
what are you guys gonna be doing oh
you're talking about yeah on thursdays
every thursday right that's the plan i
may have jury duty tomorrow so this is
the first episode yeah i figured out but
yeah yeah we're gonna um we're gonna
play the game and we're gonna uh add
factors and
uh
difficulties for instance you know maybe
we'll play naked because apparently
us
both yes
oh yeah of course and link but uh we're
gonna play the game differently and you
know
throughout each episode we're gonna uh
you know spend a little time with
physics maybe we'll go snowboarding um
but the plan is by the end of each
episode we're gonna make a run at ganon
with the rules that we've set the rules
we set and it's gonna be fairly
early game
for the most part we're not gonna spoil
anything but we're definitely gonna have
enough like
equipment to give us enough variables to
choose from yeah
is this gonna be a live stream and then
archived or is it all yeah pre-recorded
okay cool and then this is what time
planned
tomorrow thursdays thursdays uh 10 30
a.m 10 30 a.m pacific time that's right
so i was watching another
specifically specifically time for those
watching i'm in a different region
really excited for that
yeah
pete you know one thing that i don't
think breath of the wild does
you can't
become a painting and warp onto walls
like you can in a link between worlds
can you you mean like this mike
yeah
you're doing it
there we go there's the original one
you thought i forgot about it didn't you
can you do that in breath of the wild i
don't think so wow you did it that many
times you gave that game a 10 out of 10
when you can't even do this
gd
wall walk thing
did i fall asleep at my house watching
this sometimes yeah i love that like
it's really good i love that look at the
end where your face is still doing it
but your body's not right
you look slightly uncomfortable but okay
oh i think they're just looping it now
wow
yeah there it is your face just stayed
in it your face was still painting on
the wall all right uh
i would say enough of that but there's
never enough we gotta use that in the
intro for the show i think just make the
lobby intro that all right everybody uh
yeah so let us know what you think of
breath of the wild uh the triforce
starts tomorrow we are streaming
overwatch at one today for international
women's day uh chastity and shiva will
be playing overwatch playing as all the
women characters a lot of which in that
game are badass my favorite character
anna
she's pretty sweet i would say swear
more but pete's giving me this stern eye
uh again we got that giveaway i'm gonna
have rob model these quick
um
oh if you
here we have a pixel pals luigi
and then we have toad and peach amiibo
uh if you want to retweet
um gamespot's tweet uh shiva did put in
the chat earlier but if you don't just
go to gamespot's twitter account follow
gamespot if you don't already uh retweet
it and later in the week we will pick a
winner and you could receive these as
part of our we have this like uh nick
margarita memorial library of limited
edition toys and games and whatnot so
we're kind of just trying to empty it
out by giving it to our fans uh so
yeah later in the week hopefully you
will
be a winner may nick rest in peace
yes
you said nick memorial library nick
margarita memorial library that's what
we call our fault
yes may he rest in peace uh anyway
thanks again for joining stream at 1pm
so stick around uh the triforce starts
tomorrow sunday next episode of reboot
uh show jake decker and i work on it's
kind of like it's inspired by daniel
dwyer's the point when he left we want
to do an opinion editorial show i talk a
lot about breath of the wild it's pretty
much about breath of the wild
um
just wanted to pimp that i won't talk
too much more about it but that'll be
sunday at 3 p.m
uh yeah check that out if you want to
kind of look at breath of the wild even
deeper thanks so much spoilers on it
no good it's yeah it's we made sure to
keep that spoiler free so if you haven't
played or if you're
playing 100 hours and don't still don't
want something spoiled then still feel
free to stop by and watch that anyway
everybody thanks so much for joining and
we will see you next week on the lobby
[Music]
you